the will they won't they Saga over
renewing the Orville have we finally got
an answer welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV and movie channel
[Music]
several months now we've been talking
about this Orville season 4 the will
they won't they will Hulu bring us a
season four now I told you about eight
or nine months ago it looked like it was
a no but then there was a ray of hope
some of the actors started talking about
how they had been conversations and I
found out exclusively and first on
Sidetrack that actually they were having
a conversation but that they were trying
to negotiate season four at a much lower
cost than New Horizons New Horizons was
expensive they really threw a lot of
weight behind that show hoping to get
big numbers sort of Star Trek numbers
they didn't even though the series was a
success reasonably and it was popular
with the Orville fans it never quite got
the numbers that Executives at Hulu were
hoping for they were hoping for far
greater far wider audience now they
still got really good viewing hours
because the Orville fans watched the
show over and over again personally I've
watched it three times
so it wasn't a failure by any stretch of
the imagination but the world we're
living in today is very different to the
world we had when New Horizons was
commissioned we have a cost of living
crisis and people cutting back on
streaming services we have now the right
to strike and a possible act to strike
the reality today is very different
there's also an issue with Hulu itself
Disney actually do have an agreement in
place to buy the portion of who they
don't currently own it's for about 20
billion dollars or something it's a deal
that now Disney feel that one they can
no longer afford the having to cut jobs
the having to cut costs at every
opportunity they can but also they feel
that actually the price that was agreed
is just too much the reality is that
when that deal was agreed the world was
a very different place as we say and
actually now they feel that the price
should be much lower so that is causing
a significant amount of uncertainty at
Hulu an uncertainty that adds to the
Orville's problems
so
there was a streaming War
nobody won that war nobody
and everybody now except maybe Apple are
having to cut costs we discussed this
several months ago as a main reason why
in the negotiations for the Orville were
going so slowly but it seemed that fussy
door Productions Seth macfarland's
company were willing to bring that show
in at a much lower budget so
negotiations continued it then was
announced by us that actually Seth
MacFarlane was probably not going to
return to the Orville series if it got
renewed he's currently doing the Ted
show which actually on the peacock
Network they really think they've got a
hit on the hands they're really throwing
everything behind it they really think
it could be one of the big shows for
2023 2024
Seth macfarland is also currently
developing and writing the shrouded
College which is potentially going to be
a big television production again for
the peacock network based around a
series of graphic novels by Charles
suleis and will silney now sule is
actually well known within the comic
book and graphic novel Arena he has done
loads of big projects He has worked for
the MCU Etc he's done Daredevil he's
done Captain America he's done all sorts
he's done pretty much everything and his
seriously shrouded college has been
looked at for quite some time as the
next big comic book graphic novel series
now Seth MacFarlane has got his hands on
it for the peacock Network what is this
show about well it's about basically a
bunch of superheroes that are recruited
to fight any Supernatural Cold War and
that this shrouded college is a kind of
failing organization that is desperately
battling against the forces of evil now
I have no clue what certain Farm is
going to do with this whether it's going
to be a comedy whether he's going to
actually going to do a straight laced
but what we can be confident about is
that it is taking a lot of his time up
and that with Ted and a couple of other
projects he's got on the go meant he was
probably not going to return to the
Orville more than maybe a cameo role in
the first couple of episodes the
conversation that was being had was
basically he would return and either be
killed off or promoted and that actually
Captain Grayson would take over leading
the show and the ship
now I actually think that was a really
good idea and negotiations were going on
for quite some time my sources are
telling me that negotiations however
ended about three weeks ago and that
basically
there's no more Orville there are no
more plans they basically think that
without Seth MacFarlane it really loses
its weight and it just is a project that
they can no longer afford
now this is seriously disappointing I
was really looking forward to season
four of the Orville the Orville actually
was one of my favorite shows when it
first came out but can I understand why
executives are maybe pulling the cord
kind of yeah I kind of thought that the
show never really quite found its feet
it didn't really quite know what it was
was it a Star Trek show or was it a
second McFarlane show their second file
and seemed to want to do a Star Trek
show and in the first two seasons Under
Pressure I imagine from Hulu and Disney
he injected a lot of his humor into it
now in the third season Horizons a lot
of that humor disappeared and he really
did try to do a grown-up proper sci-fi
show
but that really meant that the show felt
very different in the third season now a
lot of people pointed woke at this show
and all this sort of thing and well
anybody that did that doesn't know Seth
MacFarlane they really need to go back
and watch a lot of his other material to
know what sort of humor he has and what
sort of politics he has and I don't want
to get into that argument because it's a
nonsense
but for me the show actually was a
decent success yes okay they spent too
much money on it now I always felt that
Seth macfarland probably knew this was
the last hurray for the Orville that
actually had other projects coming along
that were going to take up his time and
at the end of the day I think he felt
that Hulu didn't have the appetite for
the show the Orville season 3 really did
end in quite a nice way and maybe we
could argue that it's a decent place to
end the show
but I felt there was more adventures in
that Universe I would have liked to have
seen Captain Grayson I'd have liked to
seen what the other crew could have done
and I'd have liked to have seen where
maybe new people would have taken the
ideas to separate Fallen lay down
it's a shame that we're not going to be
getting a season four of the Orville but
guys I'd love to know what you think
please get into the comments and tell me
is this heartbreaking news are you
gutted we're not going to be getting a
season four or by this point are you
actually like well yeah we'd have heard
something by now if it was I honestly
think the final nail in the coffin of
this was the right to strike and the
potential actor strike that's coming
lots of projects are getting canceled
and this is just one more
so get into the comments Doc and tell me
exactly what you think about this news
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification really helps us out and you
can follow all the links that are
mentioned down here for lots of
Sidetrack fun stuff as always please
stay safe I'll see you next time
foreign